foreign
forced their way into Peru's oldest
university
student activists had allowed protesters
to stay there for peruvians who traveled
to Lima to protest against President
Nina voluarte
the university accused the protesters of
stealing security gear and called in the
police to a victim a steer gas was fired
terrified students tried to hide more
than 200 people were arrested but when
they were taken to the counter-terrorism
police headquarters the anger only
deepened we're asking for the freedom of
our brothers who have been detained from
different regions I feel impotent angry
in pain the police are killing our
brothers
police blocked the station's entrance
keeping out lawyers and families of the
students
unfair what they've done with the
students in a democracy
to participate but we are in a pure
police dictatorship there are no more
rights they're lost
the order is not to allow anyone to
protest the government says the police
are protecting citizens and the rule of
law former congresswoman Indira wilka
says the government has turned into a
dictatorship
we are in a dictatorship in the making
unfortunately president boluarte is
being part of a civilian military regime
it has already implemented a dictatorial
model because of what we're seeing now
with the detainees
on Saturday the European Union condemned
the violins and what it called the
disproportionate use of force by the
police more than 50 peruvians have died
since protests began six weeks ago
international human rights groups are
calling for independent investigations
but for now the government says the
police is doing its job Lima